bonjour je m'appelle Fayette Valérie
j'ai 21 ans j'habite à Saint-Benoît j'ai
le permis et je suivais je recherche une
entreprise dans le secteur est pour
effectuer un contrat de
professionnalisation de niveau 3 afin de
préparer un type professionnel manager
univers marchand d'une durée de 15 mois
j'ai fait une année de BTS Assistant
Manager je suis diplômée d'un bac pro
commerce et d'un BEP Vente d'action
marchande j'ai eu plusieurs expériences
professionnelles durant mes études dans
le commerce et dans l'administratif pour
le commerce et dans le prêt-à-porter les
commerces de détails et grandes
distribution au poste d'employés de
rayon vendeuse conseiller en vente et
pour l'administratif le poste était
agent de mistralif et d'accueil je suis
une personne responsable motivée et
ambitieuse si mon profil vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à m'appeler